so i i got this is photoshopped
it can't be what do you mean oh
what this picture of toby i suppose it
could be
i mean it can't be maybe photoshop who
says it can't be
immediately deny it right away it can't
be photoshopped impossible
it looks like an authentic photograph
all right you would have had to have
done a lot of work to get under his
little hair flap there and make the
trees work and plop
people do a lot of work to bully that's
into believing
when i see it when i see it gee
i'll believe it when i see it i'm gonna
give it
instantly you're just like no for not
photoshop
testament to how badly i want to believe
it
[Music]
spotted warren spotted warren
radioactive spotted warren
spot awards radioactive spiderwort i'm
with it
we're gonna watch today from cosmic
wonder mages stubby mcguire spider-man
no way home news
toby confirms he's in the movie he's a
menace how's it going everybody it's
warren welcome back to the cosmic wonder
and over the weekend
some interesting spider-man no way home
news happened and this particularly is
about the most
exciting thing coming up about
spider-man knowing home in my own
opinion tom hall that is the possibility
of totally
fire my favorite character sam raimi
universe possibly appearing
in spider-man no way home now i say
possibly because marvel and sony haven't
actually come out and confirmed this
officially yet
we have tons of proof tons of evidence
including some new evidence that we're
going to go over today
pretty big evidence and the spider-verse
itself is 100
from the movie so it's pretty much
confirmed but we're still waiting for
sony and marvel
and of course we're still waiting for
that trailer hopefully it comes pretty
soon but today we have
some big news to go over about toby
maguire andrew garfield and of course
tom holland get this right now they are
in the same
place which means they could be getting
ready
for spider-man who knows but we'll talk
about it so
if you love spider-man and want to stay
up to date on everything wow
i kind of want to just skip ahead and to
hear what's going on here
in the same place come on warren front
load about what we call the big three no
not aliens wizards and androids
but the big spider-man 3 of course
andrew garfield spider-man
tom holland spider-man and toby maguire
spider-man so check this out
right now they are reportedly all in new
york
toby maguire has been spotted he
apparently kind of confirmed in a way
that he was in the movie to one
particular fan
but andrew garfield has also been
spotted in new york and apparently tom
holland is going to new york today
meaning all three spider-man who are
rumored to be in the film
well i guess tom holland's confirmed to
be in the film tom holland andrew
garfield and toby mcguire are now all in
the same place
tom holland andrew garfield and toby
mcguire are all together
to possibly do some type of promotion
however if this
is the case that means that sony and
marvel
are planning on revealing that both the
other spider-man
are in the film and that they're going
to reveal that in the very first
teaser that we get otherwise toby
mcguire and andrew garfield wouldn't
really need to be there for
promotion you see yes they they very
well
could i can believe they're all in new
york
one of the biggest places in all of
america
especially if you're an entertainer if
you said like they're all in michigan
right now
what the hell they're all doing
louisiana
the odd part would be like what's toby
mcguire working on what's he filming why
is he going he could just be traveling
maybe they're all in damien chazelle's
babylon when you say same place i was
like what do you mean they're staying at
the same hotel
but if they're all in new york you know
it could they could just be in new york
yeah it could be a coincidence probably
just kicking it
but i think it's also spotter related
let's be real people come on why the
hell would i doubt that for a
second especially with toby mcguire you
know the game is so long it makes sense
in fact they really wouldn't want them
there because that would just spoil
everything that would basically confirm
that they are in the movie and if
they're not going to show that yet
they're not going to have them there but
this is really interesting because this
has been a question of many fans
including myself for
a very long time if the two of them
andrew garfield and toby mcguire are
indeed in no way home
when exactly will they reveal that could
it be in the very first teaser trailer
will it be in the full trailer will it
be
in a tv spot right before the film
releases or could it just simply be
in the film they don't tell us wait
until it's intense i personally think
that they are going to show us
beforehand because that is just going to
hype the movie up
so much and get so many people to go i'm
so conflicted because
i would prefer for it to just be shown
until the film comes out that would be
the most grand way to experience it
however
our coverage of the movie would get a
lot more views
that's the problem everyone i'm sure is
having right now is what do we do about
especially from the marvel sony
perspective yeah we could probably
guarantee
the entire world will see this movie if
we just tell him exactly but also i mean
word of mouth is gonna travel that
opening weekend and then you know maybe
they can play a long game in keeping it
a secret can you imagine how the
promotional material the anticipation
would only skyrocket for them
show it to the trailer show
just toby mcguire and garfield just make
it the opening scene from the original
spider-man movie and like i said in the
beginning at this point it's pretty much
confirmed and we actually got some kind
of
interesting proof over the weekend for
toby maguire being in the movie
said toby mcguire has been spotted in
new york and in fact
one lucky fan saw him in the streets in
washington park
and got to take a selfie with him
mcguire took a
selfie damn toby mcguire fan and a
spider-man fan
you know all of the rumors about him
possibly appearing in no way home
is the kind of guy who would take a
photo with somebody i would be kind of
nervous to approach
that person's exact name but their
instagram handle is caldes underscore
portugal
now yesterday he posted a photo of him
and toby
in new york at washington park on
instagram and of course
people started to ask him did you
mention the new spider-man movie in
which he responded
i did mention it and he said he can't
talk about it
now there is a second part to this but
let's first stop and talk about this
part because
obviously one if toby is in the movie he
can't just straight up say
yeah i'm in the movie of course all
these actors sign ndas which
stands for a non-disclosure agreement
national basketball
i got it that's hilarious john so i i
got
dude this is photoshopped it can't be
what do you mean oh what this
picture of toby i suppose it could be i
mean it can't be maybe
photoshop who says it can't be just
immediately deny it right away
it can't be photoshopped impossible it
looks like an authentic
photograph all right you would have had
to have done a lot of work to get under
his little hair flap there and make the
trees work and plop
people do a lot of work to [ __ ] us
into believing
when i see it when i see it g
i'll believe it when i see it i'm gonna
give it deeper
instantly you're just like no for not
photoshop
testament to how badly i wanna believe
it
i'm just blind right away yes it can
absolutely
you don't need to say anything more
that's it i'm going to continue with the
reaction
it's problem solved
which stands for a non-disclosure
agreement which basically means
the national basketball association dude
i love that joke
so legally he can't even say if he's in
the movie
but he also didn't say no i'm not in the
movie which
pretty much is going to happen if he is
indeed
not in the film look i'm not the
werewolf
said no he just claims that he's not the
werewolf he has
technically denied that he is going to
be in the movie and all toby would have
to do is say hey
yeah no i've heard all the rumors i'm
not in the movie sorry
but he didn't he just simply said i
can't talk about it however it goes even
further
this person goes on to say all
seriousness he's gonna be in the new
movie i know that for a fact he's gonna
do another movie and then that's it wait
no that could mean whatever this person
simply saw him on the street
he's not his best friend or anything but
when somebody went on to ask
now what was his expression when you
asked about spider-man no way home
he replied with he winked at me and
smiled
which if this is true is pretty much a
hundred percent
confirmation that he is indeed going to
be in the movie because why else would
he do that
he's not going to give his fans a false
sense of hope that spider-man a
character that
so many people love is going to be this
guy could be bullshitting
spider-verse and other spider-man as
well now of course i'll just acknowledge
that there is the possibility that this
person is lying however the photograph
is real and toby has been spotted in new
york and this year
in new york and i feel like if you are a
true spider-man fan and toby said no i'm
not in the film you would simply say
that
and at this point in time we seemingly
have so much proof and evidence that
this film
is going to feature all three spider-man
this story just lines up with everything
else
keep in mind the actual spider verse is
confirmed we are just waiting on the
confirmation
of the three spider-man now one
interesting thing to finish today's
video off
is that a russian theater chain posted
something about spider-man knowing home
that
involved the three spider-man they
posted a picture of andrew garfield on
their instagram
with the caption saying and keep in mind
this is translated from russian
one of the most anticipated films the
joint project of marvel and sony
spider-man no way home will appear
on the screens this year and this trio
will unite to fight oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
kevin feige and saudi and marvel they
must just be having panic attacks left
and right
just like how how difficult is it to get
through to people
stop confirming this don't talk about it
it's easy we give you a simple list of
stuff we don't want you to confirm
what rule just don't don't confirm this
please
either that or this is their whole
marketing campaign and we'll get no
trailer and we'll just keep getting
these instagram posts that go up for
like 20 minutes and then get taken down
i mean the trailer's gonna be kevin
foggy walking in front of a white
background
saying look guys people have ruined too
much [ __ ] there's no trailer no
trailer no footage all right you got the
title that's all you do another release
date go watch the movie
hope you enjoy yourselves we've seen
this happen plenty of times with certain
cast members of certain films
posting a little bit too much in which
case one of the studios
asked them to delete it and probably
something similar happened here although
it's not the first time they've posted
about spider-man in fact they actually
wish toby maguire happy birthday
yesterday
but again all just more proof that toby
mcguire and andrew garfield are indeed
going to be in no way home and i am
curious if they're all in new york
together for a particular reason
is this coincidence or could something
big be happening very soon
if they all are their force better
promoting three
separate movies
because again they're not going to
advertise them for any type of promotion
unless they actually do reveal this but
hopefully we'll get a little bit more
information pretty soon and if they all
are there for the same reason then we
are definitely getting something soon
so they're interviewing for a job at the
miss paper you know any of the latest
lin-manuel miranda's also in new york
right now
oh dude spider-man he's spider-man too
oh my god imagine despite he can
resurrect spider-man turn off the dark
that's what we really need that's the
multiverse i want to live in
this world manuel miranda's spider-man
turn off the dark lights of broadway
yes remember boy falls from sky the
video's ending now john spider-man
thank you ward for putting that together
revealing that information
sure why not i'll believe it i have
checked that box in my heart
subscribe to warren's channel the cosmic
wonder always on top of this
spidey news click that notification bell
for us
yo like buttons leave your thoughts down
below
should they show toby and andrew in the
first trailer should they wait till the
movie
will you be kind of bummed if they show
it but you'll still watch that trailer
over and over
i know you freaking [ __ ] see an
[ __ ]
background just like why would they ruin
that i hate that but here you
are in that video watching the trailer
leaving that comment
we're done
[Music]